[Music]
welcome back to all the burger we're
talking about
whatever we want and uh off camera
ed you were telling us about your
experience
with would you say it's a cult it's not
or it's like a
it's a self-help seminar well a lot of
cults
can't be there yeah but they i love the
self-help world yeah
it's a self-help thing you know it's
like a seminar style there's like a
bunch of people like a retreat too it's
a retreat style it's a three-day thing
but unlike colts this self-help place is
just like hey if you can get
the more friends you get in the better
yeah the more friends that pay the
better your progress is that's exactly
right see that's different than a call
and you can make money recruiting your
friends
yeah because you self-help your bank
account while you're self-helping
yourself yeah pretty good it's true they
never
really if you don't know what the
product is then you are the product
yeah just not to be in any kind of
trouble about it but
um they i was going through a tough time
yeah
i left l.a and i went back home to work
at my parents store why did you leave
l.a in the first place were you already
having a hard time in l.a uh
my uh dad had passed away my mom was at
the store by herself
um and my brother and sister already did
their time there and then it was just
kind of falling on me
like you know it's your turn kind of
deal yeah i had to face that and just
ultimately
kind of went but it was really
depressing because when i first got to
la
the thought was if i have to ever have
to go back home
i'm a failure i failed it seems to be
the common thought of a lot of
transplants here but you're like jimmy
stewart at the old building alone
i mean i was born you have family here
it's my mom's up there
so i was doing my duties as a
son i guess um to go up and dealing with
it was pretty rough
the first month and two and so
signed up for these self-help classes
and these seminars why did you do that
one instead of like something like
gary vee or like tony robbins or like
something that's just like
more known because a friend had actually
invited me
like you guys ah yeah usually as a
friend
hey uh you look like you want to make
full-time money on a part-time basis hey
do you like to make money or you don't
like to make money
well the thing is it was a 200 class
right and actually they never talked
about anyone's finances or anything it
was literal
oh so it's more culty like you want to
help yourself yeah it was behavioral
health
like therapy let's quote that whatever
it is
um changing your perspective and looking
through your blind spots in your life
there's
of podcasts by the way on youtube that
you could have watched for free
i had no idea and i had no answers
pretty much
just kind of [ __ ] signed up for this
thing should have signed up for
money masters maybe a lot of people
profited off of that program i'll have
you know
while they helped themselves and tantric
experts right
tantric sex experts and there was light
cold stuff in there very light very
light
like the colts yeah that's the ma i mean
you know that's part of it but yeah
yeah they were pretty much helping me
get through like my resentment
resentments in life in the first three
days so it was a little bit helpful
super helpful i called family members
and people i was angry at to just ask
for forgiveness because i hated them
you know wait you ask for forgiveness
because you hate them well obviously
saying
hey um this event happened and i saw it
this way
and i know you don't and i'm like and i
was the one that presented you and hated
you over
something like it was just growing up
that's pretty cool they offered a chance
to
to deal with some difficult whole lots
things yeah
they teach you how to be weak
i would have been like yo dawg this is
what you do you hate this [ __ ]
i'ma let you borrow my flame thrower and
you go to their house and you [ __ ]
burn it down
and then your problems burn away thank
you that was two thousand dollars
bye there's definitely like a
a submission aspect to it because a lot
of people go up there and they share
about why they hate their
family or their friends or some [ __ ]
something happened to them
don't you see and then whoever's up
there the leader guy
kind of breaks that [ __ ] down on them
just through the questions he asks
kind of like [ __ ] it's your perspective
it's a lot of that kind of training
always is man it's how you tell your
damn story in your own mind
how many people were up there was you
were like there was about 150 people in
that room whoa that's a lot
so they're like it's your turn ed come
with us were you wearing a white robe
and everything and [ __ ] and you had a
[ __ ]
crown and it's just regular shirts and
jeans well that's not a real cult dude
i wanted everybody to be in jumpsuits
robes or like
i wanted to look like a conference from
like a tony robbins
kind of hotel kind of thing yeah like
just
a conference room and was there like
motivational quotes those always get me
like only you can change yourself
a mouse fell into a bucket of cream
you turning and turning i was that mouse
they don't actually have any of that no
analogies no
metaphors whack bro just want you to
look at reality
kind of and like for life so um oh no
wonder they're not as successful as tony
robbins
so where's the like coltsey kind of part
or like what ended up happening i see
the
aspect of um how
not they don't break you down they don't
like tell you you're a piece of [ __ ]
and in that kind of submission they
really want you to think critically in
your position in life so they
help you they help you the more you
explain this man it just sounds like
dope ass people that are helping you
work through your [ __ ]
and you're just paying 200 bucks for it
it's way cheaper than a therapist it
sounds like you're trying to help us
where's the part where they're like and
then i had to drink breast milk right
that part never came
they were genuinely helping me um deal
with like my
[ __ ] attitude my resentment and my
[ __ ] shitty
nature and so many aspects damn it
helped me grow up
really fast in three days wow yeah so
i signed up for the second classes the
advanced classes
um and it's a lot of [ __ ] like let's say
you have something to complain about
so you write it down right and they
partner you up
and they say read each other's story of
when you that time you were hurt
and then the thing is they make you do
it for like 40 minutes
you have to read that story over and
over and over again until you're [ __ ]
tired of yourself complaining
that's pretty cool that's genius because
i'm like
god damn i don't want to hear this [ __ ]
anymore especially with your own [ __ ]
so i'm [ __ ] tired of myself i was
growing the [ __ ] up
yeah and so it was came the time for me
to share
about how i'm growing and uh
i was talking about how
i uh you know was seeing life you know
back home like
it was hard to accept that i'm here i
see it as a failure but now
you know i want to try to make this work
or whatever
and they were like yeah why don't you
tell us why you're really here
what happened right there seems to be
something else you make it noble like
you're you're helping your mom that's
why you're here
right tell us what really happened and i
was like
i tried to kill myself and i started
crying
damn started crying from and i saw
people shocked and like
tearing up and then the leader took the
mic and he goes
well ed we're not that kind of uh
organization we're not actually a
medically licensed or
so um we're gonna have to take you to
the back well we'll give you a full
refund um but we can't have you stay
here anymore
we'll take a quick break he's like oh
this guy he might kill himself yo that's
a liability dude he might kill himself
on our program
[ __ ] this [ __ ] let's get this nut crack
out of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey i'm sorry man we're gonna give you a
full refund no you know what we're gonna
get 5 000
and you take this money and you go this
is why we didn't let anyone talk during
money masters except for us
what's the [ __ ] all kinds of
liability you're taking on so
i sat there in my car like damn
even self-help classes don't want to
help me oh no damn
you know i feel that sucks but this is
so
[ __ ] funny man i couldn't help but
laugh in my car wow do you want to even
continue the ball i can't
like no as soon as like i got to my car
and i'm sitting in silence like
damn your body's not good here we can't
help you refund
dude imagine all the people in the room
who have had the same thought though and
they're all just like
okay you gotta button up about that yeah
i can't
you know what i mean that's a great way
to get a refund
so uh i mean honestly what happened was
i had to look at life for
exactly they already taught me that
right and even these guys are rejecting
me
that's hilarious but the reality was to
no one's gonna help you
no one's here for you you know like and
i had to
find and guide my way through this
existence pretty much
like knowing that i have to kind of make
these decisions
um the way i want to to be in control of
this [ __ ]
right so it's not like i went back so
they actually helped you by throwing you
out
because if you were dependent on them
they could have been much richer
much much richer what if they watch this
video and they go so we did end up
helping i'm gonna charge you again yeah
you're like can i get that money back
sounds like a lot of value pal
it seems like it helped you i mean it
brought me towards more of a critical
way of thinking um and facing life and
a lot of the challenges this episode is
brought to you by audible.com
and you know what's cool about
audiobooks
so you know i like to work out i like to
get my hands busy wash a little
bit of the dishes or just regular life
movement right yeah
and to read a book you have to actually
like schedule out
time to sit down open it up and be hella
focused but
sometimes you just want to like hear
thoughts as you're still doing other
things
and me i like to like do a lot of
projects right yeah but i have to remind
myself
why i want to do this so i have this
really
good book that i'm on and i'm listening
to on audible called start with why
i love that and it's a classic by simon
sinek right
um and i can listen to this or read this
book
multiple times because it's almost like
a reset
like if i'm gonna create a new product
if i'm gonna get into a new business
venture
or even like get into creatives and like
why i wanna make
this film or whatever it is right it
kind of helps
adjust my mind to start it with a great
motivation
of like why i'm trying to do this in the
first place and is it
for the right reasons and so that's why
i just absolutely love like sometimes
listening to podcasts or audio books
because i'm able to still do what i'm
gonna do but like listen as i like
double multitask yeah you know what i
realized too about myself is actually
learn better from listening i've read
the book
and i think some for some reason i don't
retain the information as well but when
i'm listening especially with like
headphones on
and i'm like jogging or something like i
retain the information so much more
because afterwards when i talk to geo
about it i can actually explain exactly
what the whole chapter is about
without my mind going blank like wait
what is that chapter about so that's why
i really like
audiobooks and the cool thing is they
don't only have
audio books okay they have podcasts
they have live theatrical performances
they have audible originals they have so
much more content than just
audiobooks yeah and if you go to audible
plus they have the whole plus catalog
too so there's an endless amount of
content so if you guys want to check out
audiobooks
for your drive for your commute for your
doing your dishes or your daily
errands go to audible.com off the record
or you could text off the record
to 500-500 that's visit audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500.
what do you think change yeah i mean you
got to give yourself credit because
i mean you know other i mean there could
have been
like oh even they don't want me well i
better off myself then because i'm
helpless
right so like there's so many paths but
you chose
like [ __ ] this dude like they're not
gonna help me i gotta help myself they
literally rejected you and you chose to
see it as a good thing which is
right which is that you did it though
that's the thing but but what would you
say
looking back at your old self is the
difference
like is there some kind of like what was
the perspective shift
if you is there one thing is there
multiple things like like the beef like
the then and not because
you you've had such a drastic change and
it's so fresh
where most people take a long time like
for me if i was asked that like it was
it's so long that i can't identify the
change right but yours is like you said
three days you're a different person
this and that what was the thing that
separated the two
um projection the that when i hate
somebody
and all the things i hate about them are
definitely just the traits i own
wow it's a constant looking in the
mirror
it's constantly pointing when you cringe
at something is because
that's the part that you hate and you
see it in other people
damn that's next level that's [ __ ]
next level i cringe a lot
all the time me too but it's dead that
has nothing to do with me i'll tell you
what there's something
you know what i i i cringe at myself a
lot a lot of the past stuff i've done
right
but then and so i'll sit by myself and
just hate
myself right but the
other reality of thinking about how much
i hate myself
is just exponentially how much more i
love myself
that's true yeah when i'm in the car by
myself and i'm in my own thoughts like
you say there's
it's really loud in your brain right i'm
in the same way
sometimes i just just scream i [ __ ]
hate myself
right and then as soon as i say that i'd
be like no wait
i love myself i just drive down the
street
i love myself it's just it's just as
true as how much i hate myself isn't it
you're really into yourself yeah
so i have you care too that much i care
so much
up or down
and he does it with a full car david's
in there like
yo shut up man what the [ __ ] are you
doing so i
i i saw that like i'm [ __ ] rejected
by people who said they were going to
help me you know
and i had to look at the saddest part
about it
and also the funniest part it is
hilarious man that's why we need humor
though
yeah and people try to take it from us
so often but you you chose to find this
situation humorous
and many people could twist it and go
all who are those [ __ ] [ __ ]
them all this [ __ ]
but it's like you you you owned this
moment and you
yeah anymore when you use humor
you own your own story and so as when i
see the
pain in my life like i totally started
understanding the
that those drama faces where it's sad
and crying it's the
same [ __ ] feeling all right that's
true i feel pain
and i can cry or be angry or i can
[ __ ] laugh
two sides of the same coin yeah and i
can
i can definitely feel everything though
it's okay to feel
pain it's always okay to feel angry
about that pain
and it's also okay to laugh it's just
everything
we all feel it's how is it not okay to
laugh then right
so being able to see that you were just
projecting yourself
uh and your negative traits on other
people right um
did that help you identify when you were
cringing
or like when you were blaming or when
you were angry at others
like were you able to be like oh [ __ ] ed
check
is and then did you work your way
through that or i'm constantly now in a
place where um
i do review the way i um
interact with my relationships towards
people because
of the way i might say something to them
because of
the way i might disrespect them with my
words kind of thing
and in the past i didn't give two shits
that's me
or whatever but more or less if i'm
interacting and i'm going to be around
people
like why would i make it shitty for them
where in the past i never gave a [ __ ]
you're just like this is hawaiian take
me or leave it
we click we click if we don't then
that's on you but even in
people who are close proximity yeah of
me which is a [ __ ] dumb thing to do
um and so yeah you'll end up with no
friends and i mean i'm still
having i still have trouble with my
relationships in that matter but i can
go up to
and now say i'm sorry i said so before
you couldn't say sorry
i've had problems with you never lose
[ __ ] yeah you killed the ego
then he's like i think a lot of like
self-help things also kind of identify
like
like what you're dealing with it's like
we have our true self
and then we have like the ego self right
and that ego is always there to kind of
not let your truth be heard or or even
known to yourself right you kind of like
destroyed it in those three days and i
feel like a lot of people take a
lifetime figuring that out yeah that
psychology of that is
a hard journey to go through well and
it's a journey too right it's not over
it sounds like you're still going
through this true all the time it's that
i couldn't identify what exactly i
needed to do to be
a better person i just knew i'm kind of
shitty right but i have no idea how to
help myself which is why i just
signed up somebody helped me help me you
know
and uh what about yourself where you're
like i'm kind of shitty
i was a major like alcoholic and
putting my like pain and hurt through
substance abuse
um made me feel a lot of shame on myself
too
all the time um
a lot of the mistakes of my past replay
in my head
and uh the traumas of the past too oh so
you couldn't let go to use alcohol to
forget you know going through that class
and
looking and reviewing my life especially
when i hit 30. my dad died when he was
53
you know and my midlife crisis had
happened
there which is why i needed to change uh
my health my body like
what i was doing to myself even how i
was thinking
you know it's not like a three-day
transformation totally um yeah i've had
a lifetime of experiences
to have to come to a point of knowing
exactly
how to take the steps to reconcile
relationships
how to redeem relationships as well and
sustain too
yeah ask for forgiveness straight up
like you know not be ashamed to be like
i'm sorry
you know and not know anything either
just
be okay with who i
am in that matter that i exist in all of
it i just
am yeah
that's really really tight thank you hey
thanks for opening up dude
that's a you are very different though
like from when i remember
it was just like the jolly fat guy to
now like the the monk
you were the monk no like you were sorry
you weren't that deep back then
like you like i feel like uh you know
the ed that i remember
was like the guy that would come around
and he'd just be a goofball and then
that's it like you know you didn't have
any deeper thoughts
were you covering up though i mean you
obviously were deeper than that yeah i
mean because when i was
23 i i
traveled a lot around the world to about
my life in philosophies
and i became a monk-ish
when i studied the [ __ ] bible
hardcore and i went to iraq
you know um lived there for two months
of the bible yeah what where in irbil
and i lived there for two months living
with the people in the middle of the war
2009 yeah what made you go there well
that's crazy
i was facing this existential crisis
in when i was 23. my life has come to a
lot of trauma
and a lot of thought where you thought
iraq would help you
but dude a lot of people just read perks
of being a wallflower they don't go to
[ __ ] iraq
i had to figure out or you could have
just gone to bali like normal people
like yeah or [ __ ] you know like via
hippie or
it is a lifetime of learning dude and i
found that amongst
strangers and people like so i went to
haiti after their earthquake
and i you know helped did some
humanitarian work
um and and then i went to japan after
the tsunami
and i cleaned up after a lot of [ __ ] and
like i always learned something
about myself too as i'm out there doing
that [ __ ] but
as when i come back home to my church
i was rejected by them too none of them
wanted to hear why you keep getting
rejected bro
yeah that's why i say i'm a piece of
[ __ ] you're like i just want to say i
helped clean up during haiti and they're
like hey this is not that place you need
to get the [ __ ] out of here
the [ __ ] is that wait so you went back
and how did they reject you they didn't
want to hear
what happened they thought i was there
on a like a
vacation to make myself like some holy
man to make myself
in a writer yeah wow and what i don't
know they
yeah it's a lot to it they they rejected
me
pretty much and so i left church and i
became an alcoholic
and i moved to l.a and that's how you
who you met was alcoholic ed who left
the church and
not in every any kind of deep thought i
just need to get my work done
that's crazy yeah i put everything into
work and alcohol
and then i just burnt out and food huh
and
food yeah yeah 150 pounds yup
and then yeah turn 30 and realize
i probably have a i don't have that much
long left because my dad died at 53.
yeah well i mean
you probably got more years on you now
since you had you changed your lifestyle
yeah yeah that's why i started fasting
yeah for longevity i
i i took away a lot of years right so
i continue to fast i seldom do this and
we can cut this if you like
but but do you feel like anyone really
knows you
dan fisher he owns fishbowl he's my best
buddy
we've known each other since high school
we
went to college together graduated
together lived together and moved to l.a
together
then he got married and now by myself so
that so that is that what it is
because so you had you had that but
maybe it's not the same oh definitely
i've
constantly been in search for like uh a
deep friendship
because i hate that surface level [ __ ]
you know because i don't like playing
video games
or yeah i'm not really actively wanting
to go play sports
kind of you know um i
my therapist even told me i have this
understanding complex
where people don't understand me
and you understand that they don't
understand you and you're like that's
okay
yeah and i've just lived with it's okay
you don't have to
what's not to understand he's [ __ ]
easy to understand
he is he is i mean i didn't know you
this way
because you didn't open up this way but
now it's like oh
yeah this i this i get it yeah it's not
complicated to know you i find
yeah but maybe i understand that you
feel like it is but
and you're not wrong you're surrounded
by morons that's the problem
yes and i can't say that out loud
because i feel bad about
saying that [ __ ] that dude i'll say it
for you
listen i've only gotten to know you
today i find it very interesting you
talked
you broke down [ __ ] christopher nolan
movies in a way i've never even heard of
my whole life
like i don't know dude yeah you're a
very interesting dude so yeah and
so i'm working at this store and i just
[ __ ] wish that these people who kept
calling me a [ __ ] and a [ __ ]
throwing [ __ ] at me or [ __ ]
physically assaulting me
or stealing my [ __ ] or pissing on my
yard
don't want to get to know me they just
want to [ __ ] with me
and so i had a longer year [ __ ] those
meth heads though
yeah having to deal with this existence
yeah yeah yeah i'm by myself too
yeah you can't it's also a shitty
environment that you're in man like you
can't thrive in shitty environments it's
it's difficult
really difficult and looking for
reaching out to people in an environment
like that
yeah yeah like like like every person
that comes into your store
trying to look for a crack pipe like you
can't make a good
you know growing friendship there like
the [ __ ] i i couldn't find it yeah at
all so like uh like i went to high
school with
lived down the street from my store
actually and he'd come in to
you know buy some caffeine or what red
bull or some [ __ ] and leave
every day just small talk and then he's
like hey why don't you come over have a
beer sometime so i do
and then he's like hey man if you your
family ever needs help call me
right and then i got assaulted
some [ __ ] uh
yeah people just start [ __ ]
it's okay then it's all good yeah uh
i called this guy up and
that's where he draws a line what do you
mean he's like i i can't help you but
i can't help you dude it's like i'm not
gonna i hate those tough
and i was you know what i [ __ ] went
back to church
the people who rejected me right and i
go
show up back to church and none of these
[ __ ] will help me
yeah which confirms your theory that
you're truly alone and nobody will ever
oh yeah consistently yeah and this is
the first year in and i was there for
four years
oh man yeah i hate comparing myself to
like prisoners
i think because that's some real [ __ ]
you know but
isolation i get it this quarantine
pandemic
i've been in it already i understand it
i've been deep in my brain alone in
solitude
for a long time maybe that's why i'm
okay with sharing so much of it yeah
because everyone else out there is also
going through this pandemic and thinking
thoughts they never thought before
because they've been alone
so it's maybe it's not normal but you're
okay
like other people feel this [ __ ] you
know
and you can come out okay and laugh at
[ __ ]
yeah and be okay with it all well come
hang out with us because we love hosting
super spreader events
[Laughter]
bart makes this amazing wuhan wagyu oh
my goodness it's
off the floor delicious
you have to try it before you hate on it
[Music]
you